you know because we always hear about
bill belichick being this defensive mind
so he had to defend you for however many
years
is it all true was it was it is it the
coaching is it the player
it's mainly the coaching and a lot of it
has to do with scouting for instance
they like how they watch film and the
scouting team right that they had this
note that whenever i adjusted my gloves
it meant it was going to be a running
play so
so every every little cue every little
cue they could find
they give it to the defensive players
and so a lot of times you're playing
patriots and they're calling out to play
before before and was that true
it's true so every time you just some
but but i mean
it wasn't true a hundred percent of the
time but not enough time to work times
where yeah
where you get a head start you know and
we ran the ball so much that
it didn't it didn't matter um but but
yeah so
and you know we played them in 2009 2008
the wildcat game
and it was the opposite because they had
never seen the wildcats so they couldn't
prepare for it and they didn't know what
to do they were running into each other
arguing on the sidelines and we it felt
so good to whip him up
yeah when y'all were doing the wildcat
it was you and ronnie brown
and at the time i i don't recall there
being a better one-two punch when you
really cause ronnie brown was a [ __ ]
monster
yeah um the cowboys they had mary and
barbara and
barbara and the other guy um i know
you're talking about um
thomas jones thomas was it thomas no
thomas jones felix jones felix
felix jones felix jones and marion
barber yes yeah yeah but
but it but the wildcat i want to say you
guys are first
at least i'm a pretty big football fan i
don't think i saw anyone do it before
you
did it well just before we did it um our
offensive coordinator our quarterbacks
coach david lee was
at arkansas and felix jones and
uh uh uh mcfadden
yeah yeah they they ran it in arkansas
wow so when when you guys decided to do
it in the nfl are you thinking like
this is [ __ ] crazy we're gonna get
ate up we're this is i was like this
i was like this high school high school
[ __ ] but then we started off on two
and then we were like okay we gotta try
some [ __ ] we gotta try some [ __ ] and so
we
we we put it in against the patriots
that first game and ronnie had like
you know had a 60 yard had 120 through
for a touchdown i had like almost 100
yards rushing
and and we ended up making the playoffs
that year